[Music]
i i always open the show with
a question you open show it
which i'd like to do a soft pitch for
just zip zap top
and maybe bing bang bong you know just
switch it up stop punching up my slopes
okay i'm sorry
the reason it works is because it's
mediocre and frankly not that ketchup
makes absolutely no sense the key to
that the reason why that's worked so
well is that no one wants to seem like
they don't get it
i was like that's so funny and it's just
like a
bruise i like it frankly so i frankly
oh frankly i open after
with are we friends can you tell the
audience
if we're friends and what our
relationship is so that i'm not gonna
full of shit be like oh my god really
best friends
and then you have to perform the whole
time sure let's just start out being
authentic
okay i want to say like at this point
it's tough because the comedy community
you see each other so often
i mean i'm not saying we see each other
all the time but even if it's just
online you're
you have like a belonging in a community
as a comic
so even with someone like i guess i'm
closer i'm just talking about her
because i just saw her but like esther
like i would say i'm closer with esther
no you came over and instantly walked
towards esther
and started and that's when you started
spiraling and i why would she choose
i literally had a full-on panic attack
and started like chasing gear down my
driveway
because i didn't feel included in the
conversation if i had known that i would
have
which by the way quick tangent which is
what a podcast is just a giant tangent
when you drove up
for some people special but yeah you saw
some deer
i did i drove up and i saw
three deer on the left and i was like oh
my god i just because i've seen so many
of your videos
like trying to find animals peeing on
stuff
i was like this is what i expected but i
truly believe that the animals we
encounter in the day are sending
messages to us
or needs subliminal or need to like
remind us of something that's obviously
not true science but why the fuck not
believe that
it was a little family of deer what do
you think they were telling you what do
you think the universe wanted to remind
you
oh like when you see a praying mantis
that's a reminder to be still
and silent maybe maybe play because the
little
yeah the little fawn was like it was
like that bad
and i was like you know and then he
jumped into the hill
or she and so i'm like it was cute it
was like a little hop they're so playful
and joyful and light and i think that's
a good reminder
obviously my job i was telling you i was
like behind on some work but it's like
you have to remember like there's play
in it have fun while you're doing it we
have
managed to i think that you know we take
such a joyful
thing sometimes i think we all do this
and then make it
miserable you know like make something
fun miserable because you turn into a
job yeah i see so many people with their
hobbies turning into like a job and
you know i have this friend who's like i
gotta go scrapbook it's like that's
supposed to be the fun thing
don't turn your fun into an obligation
yeah i think even like i told you
it's been so long since i've done stan
the last time i did stand up was filming
my special
so that's such a weird thing like it's
such a gift
because i got it done yeah and then it's
also weird because how would i rebuild
an hour like this would be now the time
where
yeah start to try to rebuild yeah so
it's almost like
speaking of what the universe is trying
to tell you it's like maybe you should
stop
yeah totally like slow down and play
yeah because you just
you know and it's also something to
think about is like so i'm not getting
up
and i'm not getting that adoration and
that love
yeah so maybe i'm seeking it other
places with men or talking to dudes or
whatever it is like
it's just interesting that i'm i'm i'm
missing that thing that i've been
getting for so many years
it's been fascinating to watch people's
coping mechanism be taken away and see
how they play whack-a-mole with their
addictions uh a lot of them i just
these are the times where you're
uncomfortable like i'm like thinking
about oh god
this is just like what's this look like
from the side look amazing i haven't
even been
you look incredible do you want to
change your no i just like
it's making me want to take this off
this reflection no no i didn't take the
reflection
i need to see it what if i like look
over and it's really bad what would have
changed
in the next two hours i mean i look you
know you look beautiful
that's very nice i look like adam doritz
but anyway um yeah why don't we turn
this off so we're not looking at
ourselves
see i have two male producers in the
room that are like don't know about body
dysmorphia
and that women should never look at
their own reflections so we have to
turn this off honestly i i really
honestly i said don't turn it off and
the minute
it went off i was like oh my god
we were both having a conversation
secretly stealing glances at ourselves
in the moment okay the whole time i mean
i know i'm gonna slouch like for sure
you know they say that if you were to
see yourself in the wild
you wouldn't even be able to recognize
yourself that's how dysmorphic we are
like if you saw beth in the wild you
wouldn't even know it was i'd be really
upset sometimes when i'm eating i'm like
somebody's watching and capturing this
and i will have to look at it later and
i won't recognize and you won't
recognize yourself i thought that it's
so wild how dysmorphic we are
you have some dysmorphic stuff i have
like a joke where i say
i have reverse body dysmorphia because
if you don't know body dysmorphia it's
when you think you're fat but you're
actually
stupid no no no there's other reasons
like
mothers and being brainwashed by
doctored images of other women since the
time we could see
yeah it's so funny and then you came up
i learned so much in the moment that you
came up because you're like i'm so
broken out and i was like what oh yeah
and i was like i do that where i upset i
like i
don't see that you're i'd have to really
look we went on such a long tangent that
it didn't answer the question of if we
were a friend no i'll get back to you
okay don't you worry because skin is
something we have uh
bonded on and you've been there for me
on that yeah so what uh here's my thing
i feel like we should be better friends
right i uh i think it's weird that we're
not
you imagine coming like me you know
you've been
doing it longer you're you are famous
and so when we have
those moments like where you like i
it's i guess i'm sure how can i describe
it i would never assume that you wanted
to be friends with me
which is weird because you i think of
you as this like
sort of paragon of like cool comedy you
know what i like about you
what you let people come to you that's
true
i kind of always have been like that
even with my comedy like you know i get
on stage
bar in chicago and it's like loud no
one's paying attention i'm like
well if i talk like this you're probably
gonna get quiet and i'm leaving
that is truly one of the 48 laws of
power
and the art of production techniques is
to not yell the way i'm yelling
although it can be very irritating when
someone talks too light like that's
i'm trying to think someone did it to me
recently it was on a zoom yeah so if
like they want you to pay attention to
it can be very irritating when
somebody's like
group of people whether it's on zoom or
in person they're just like yeah you
know so
that's kind of like okay you know that's
a decimal level that's not going to work
yeah huh yeah it's like it's it is
you you have to make it look like and i
never did you have to make it look like
it's not a power move
because i don't think i even process
when i did it that's just how comedy
came out of me
i was basically sleeping um with my eyes
awake
i was talking very quietly i was like i
guess a little shy yeah
and so that's i never chose a persona
and i also never watched stand up
mostly because i was very scared of
stealing and thinking yeah me too that's
what so
i'm not someone who came up on stand-up
like yeah adoring them i remember
someone in high school
i don't see you doing an impression of
anyone i don't see like oh
she's like this meets this i'm always
like beth is her own
thing cool thanks yeah i think you're
your own thing too
we are different which is like i said i
it's always
important to remind people that women um
are different types of comedians there's
more than one type of
yeah i am just more yeah i i prefer the
type of
like when i play vegas for example yeah
i think you you destroy you're in a big
theater like
you know you are you're more um animated
when i play vegas i'm doing kimmel's
club and i have to open with
um just so you guys know like this isn't
going to be like but um
like over your head it's really more of
um
a scavenger hunt for my punchlines so
best of luck to all of you and let's
begin
you might be like i'm there to happen
and i'm like mine's more of a bop-up
you know mine is like you know i
you know i definitely i grew up in a
home where i was not
heard i grew up in a home where you had
to fight really hard for attention you
people were falling asleep passing out
at 5 00 p.m
people uh were having affairs they were
busy they were narcissists whatever
and i had to i mean literally to the
point i remember going to
a therapist who was like why are you
yelling like she literally we were just
like in a small room and it was just
like
i just thought this is how i had to talk
to be heard yeah so it's taken me so
long to just talk at a normal decibel
level
and it i just i'm receiving it
how self-contained it's almost like a
and and i'm comfortable now like now
that the screen's gone and i'm still
wondering like how i might look from the
side and why would we have it
me at the side you know no you're this
is your this is good
for me yeah no this is my this camera's
not okay it's just for cutting yeah so
but the thing is like i would like to
think that i'm more confident i love it
when someone that has
a stand-up special coming out on hbo max
has been on
camera for truly 14 years it's like how
do i like
that ship has sailed like the worst is
left of the bar
but we still i think people think that
when they see that we post ourselves on
social media and do specials that we
for some like our appears at peace with
our appearance in some level like
you're just here like she should be in a
tank top by the way right now i'm
wearing a tank top under here beautiful
her body's beautiful
i was like three years from now you're
gonna be like i should have been naked
every day
the way that i looked you know and still
you should be naked then too but i'm
just saying like
every year that passes is a missed
opportunity to be to
wear a tank top yeah i don't like
wearing tank tops because i don't like
how my
this my armpits make a vagina sure
it's just i get distracted when other
people don't yours is a tiny garage
there
it's not i don't want the pedophiles to
get too excited about this tiny vagina
on my shoulder
so yeah i just and i don't know i think
that i i just have i had this thing
where i i felt very codependent when you
came because i was like she's so dressed
down and chill
and like i'm gonna dress down and just
look how chill i am and she's gonna
think we're like
the same but it's like i'm not nervous
now but like my default mechanism
is a little more withdrawn pulled in
like
even filming the special i thought i've
been doing this for a long time it's my
first hour special i've done half hours
before
i thought i toured it i was like i'm
ready and still i was so surprised how
nervous i was
there it's abs it's if you're not
nervous when you're on stage in front of
a thousand people there's something
wrong you're a psychopath and it should
be nice and when it's being taped you
should be nervous
and by the way nerves are good like
there's a there's a war on nervousness
and anxiety
i am fighting every day nervousness and
anxiety
can be an engine to make you more it
makes your senses more focused it makes
you more alert it makes you
better like nervousness is not bad
there's this entitlement
among this next generation people that
like believes they should never have
anxiety
like anxiety is the reason our species
proliferated it is the
like survive truly anxiety is such a
gift it is your gut it is your instinct
it makes you hyper sensitive and like
it's it's a good
thing like if we get rid of anxiety
you'll just be in bad relationships for
the rest of your life because you won't
have
something telling you to leave yeah that
we need that's our body telling although
i've had
i have had plenty of moments where my
body and everything's telling me to
leave
and i don't or i can't and it's
different reasons each time typically
but the main one is like oh i don't want
to be mad at me
you're mad at me i'm bad i got to be
good yeah you know so you
i stay too long it's like i know i'm i'm
willing to be
unhappy with someone for up to three
years uh i just stay
extra long because you're worried about
hurting their feelings hey that's how i
get into like some jokes on this in my
special yeah
i have stayed in relationships because
truly like i'm i've been scared before
because i'm like
i'm never going to win i'm not going to
be able to get out even if i try
like i just i fully like i'm going to
be gaslit and i just don't even want to
embarrass my and then i'll feel
embarrassed and
shameful if i try and can't
successfully extricate myself or my main
breakup move
is to just be an asshole until they
break up with me
that's your main move this is my main
move works great
karmically set um where i'm like i'm
just going to be shitty and just
hope that it's classic it's not it's not
like no one's done it it is but they
don't
they usually don't even notice
i don't think i've ever like been like
this isn't working
i would love to be confident like i've
known it's
in and say it's over i'm sure about it
let's move on i mean i'm still with like
four people i just have not
i just never handled it like they just i
just
i don't even know because my thing is as
soon as you're sitting down to talk
through something you're just getting
back together
like i know i i've just historically i'm
just like i'd rather you just manipulate
me and me
i'll talk myself into this because it's
just gonna be like exhausting
to have to have this conversation i
think for me it's less and if a man
starts crying
i i like i panic you're like oh no stay
okay
i'll say like please stop crying because
it's just so unattractive related to
that like i'm
like watching a man cry is so deeply
upsetting because they start crying all
the tears they never got to cry in their
childhood and it becomes this like
uncontrollable sob that's like not even
about you but you're just like this is
just too much emotion i get it your dad
didn't say i love you now i'm like
dealing with you like trump it's like
it opens a damn that like never stops oh
god when a man cries he cries for like
four days
what just happened to me was me thinking
about like a lot of people crying
um guys yeah yeah i think
i definitely relate to that and to me
it's more it just kind of goes back to
that i don't want this person to not
like me
but i'm breaking up with them like the
goal is for you to stop loving me but i
don't want you to know
yeah because it's also the goal is i
want you to not like me so i don't hurt
you but you're like not when you keep
liking me so i can break your heart
it's so counter-intuitive like i know
what you there's what i realized with
relationships
and someone very wise said this to me
once there's no such thing as a good
breakup
stop trying to make a breakup like
perfect yeah yeah
one person's always going to be hurting
more than the other person it's always
going to be messy it's always going to
suck
stop trying to make it a good break it's
like i want an exit interview and i
would never say like
what i did what did i do wrong you know
because it doesn't mean like necessarily
anybody did anything wrong but i
am part of me does wish that there was
and i know this is
not a good idea like an uber rating at
the end like a yeah like a review
you know like really good at head talks
too much you know just
stuff like that i think they have that
it's called revenge porn uh it's all
over the internet
i'm sure you're on it i haven't checked
it's so
you were just in a relationship it would
like so i
dated um i dated someone for a couple
years i was much younger than me
and i would just say that in his life
i'm 30 and i'm 37.
is it over well i can't break up with
right right right right right
he's under the team i'm currently just
trying to be an asshole
but so but he was nine years younger
than me okay
and yeah um and why is that
why is that triumphant why is that
interesting why it is it was always
interesting on the road because i would
say it and i
there's no part of me that wanted or
expected an applause right yeah
but it does happen they're like ah good
for you good for
you you're still
fuckable but also my thing is i get so
confused when guys want to date younger
girls like we're better at sex
yeah 100 i'm sorry i'm not kidding
one guy was like you have such great
this um this sounds like some sort of
humble brag
but rest in peace harris but it's one of
those things where he was like
he said to me you have such good control
over your body like not everybody has
that
i'm just like what dead fish are you
fucking
who's not getting what they need who's
not engaging their cord right
or just like who's not getting what they
need there is something
but i was just like obviously i was kind
of flattered by that but i'm also like
who are these women and how can i get
their numbers to see when
i was younger i was not that good at sex
i was just trying to look pretty and
like stuck in my stomach
and like arch my back and like make a
lot of noise because i thought that was
sexy i had no concept of like enjoying
it and i was just like insecure and like
worried and like just trying to
emulate what i had seen in porn but i do
find that younger guys
i'm working on this theory the people in
the podcast know and we're gonna oh i'd
like to hear this
theory that younger guys have more
respect for women
i yeah i mean i that's why i can only
give you my one
experience but it was lovely i have two
instances so i dated a younger guy
like five years ago he was like 10 years
younger than me
and we were making out and look
i learned you gag on a dick that's like
what you're supposed to do
that's what you're supposed to do i have
no idea if i enjoy it
i just wa it's just what it is what it
is guys
go shopping with girls and they have to
hold the purse while they change it's
there's not always
and we're supposed to gag and they're
dead and we gag on their dicks like it's
i'm not i'm not against it i'm not pro
it
is what it is like i don't care like and
by gagging
you mean like making a sound or like
making a sound that's fake
or tears coming out of your eyes okay
you're running mascara you have to look
like you're passing away
for a guy to get a boner passing away
it's so funny
so i i don't know no i'm but i mean also
like to the point where you might
actually like
yes yes and you actually might i gag
when i brush my teeth
okay like i did i dated something like
that i'm like yeah
i could have sorry
it's like a fucking response and it's
like get it out of here
women in their thirties are like i can't
even brush our teeth anymore
our necks are so trained to gag on
anything
lunell has a great joke by the way about
like not having your head pushed in
she's like you don't know what we've
been through
get your hand off the back of her head
anyway well i just like have extensions
in
like i don't touch don't touch my head i
know how to suck your dick
i don't need you to like put your hand
on it yeah um
so i'm going down on the sky i never
talk like this in the five hours by the
way
i'm excited because i have some other
questions just like that i was wanting
to share but i wasn't sure if we were
gonna be able to talk about it i think
we
should go um if we're in a pandemic
honestly we're all going to die soon
so i go down do my thing and he was like
what are you doing like he gasped and i
was like what are you doing like what do
you mean
he was like he literally said to me uh
i'm not
turned on when women hurt themselves
i was so embarrassed i was like first of
all
i drove to your apartment from my house
also to be told that by someone who's
been here last time like a young like a
man who was just like oh no no no honey
you don't have to do that like i'm not
into like don't hurt yourself like i'm
not into hurting women that's not my
king
and i was so embarrassed because i was
like
isn't it it's hard to be vulnerable like
that like even just like sexually even
if you've been doing it for a while it
takes
well it's just like older guys like
that's just a given
right younger guys are just like wait
wait we were we grew up with beyonce
and communication i guess because like
and everybody likes
i mean maybe i'm just singing like male
comics that are like what are you
supposed to do like ask and it's like
what do you mean like it's never slowed
the
mood down like honestly you ask everyone
in the audience where they're from
yeah you can ask me if i want to fuck
you yes
or even something i'm seriously that's
the sentence can i go down on you yeah
that's a turn-on to me
yeah oh wow i know that i'm not even
saying like i need
your give you consent to go down i mean
obviously like you would think that that
would be
a given yes yeah there's good to ask but
when someone's like can i go down
anyways like it means they want to and
they're asking and yeah that's great
thank you
there's something i do think that it is
a murky area because i was dating a
younger
guy that asked me that kind of shit and
i just was like
i think because he was younger it made
me feel maternal like oh you need my
permission
like it was just like for hit me a weird
way with him once but one time he was
like can i take off your bra
and it was so hot yeah it's nice it was
like good because
it actually what the thing they're
missing is it puts you in control
yeah can i and then i get to answer yes
or no but it's all it's just hot yeah
there's something i'm not even like into
control things necessarily like to be
honest i would say
being considerate yeah yeah i was gonna
say i
i don't know about you and you don't
have to share but like i'm not like
kinky
like i'm just like pretty good like
enjoy sex in the way that's like the
normal positions
i feel like for the most i am so boring
the way i have sex that it's actually
kinky
it's so like mission like textbook that
it's actually like
full cake people you just have sex like
missionary that's fucking wild
that's some fucked up like i'm gonna say
four positions i rotate i would say
yeah i i guess it depends but i
i'm like whatever dude i broke my
shoulder a couple years ago so there's a
couple that are off limits like i
the handstand yeah like i know like a
couple tricky
spots like but i also think i'm learning
i like a dominant man
i don't like i used to be like i have to
jump on top and bounce around and
reverse cowgirl and do all this crazy
shit
never to never regret reverse never
regurgitating yeah
reverse cowgirl for me yeah i'm not
saying i've never done it i just get it
i don't like it it's it's you have to do
a lot of math
so that the day doesn't pop out it
almost feels confusing
it is really putting a circle in a
square so it is going different
like our anatomy goes the opposite way
than the dick curve so i'm also like
i feel like your dick is bending in a
weird way yeah this is like making me
look stupid and i'm
really trying to figure out where my
cervix would be i yeah it's just like a
it's a
and then but then if i start moving and
you start moving it we're gonna fuck up
rhythms
and then you just have to not move at
all have you ever broken someone's dick
no
okay me neither no i don't know oh i
mean i feel bad
no i'm saying we should not we should
try not to do that
that sounds let's make it first of all
how dare you if i had broken a guy's
dick
you eat a whole special two broke dicks
yeah i don't um i don't like having sex
in a way where i'm
thinking about my balance okay if i'm
thinking about my balance i'm not it's
not hot
100 i don't know i'm not a shower person
like a standing in the shower type
never i would never be able to reach
what are we trying to prove
yeah who's this for it's also taking
away lubrication with the water
who's i'm getting a uti like what are we
i'm someone's always
freezing i'm cold you're speaking of
blowjobs that's the thing i wanted to
ask
now this is again it's going to sound
like i'm really good at them or
something but
you know you believe you're great at
blowjobs but here's my theory like
maybe i am yeah like i feel like i'm
good at it for sure sorry
we are no we're eight or three yeah like
a lot of dicks right so i'm thinking
like
yes maybe i'm going to invest
objects for a living this is what we do
like close to ourselves
yes um wouldn't that be like just though
the move
like if you wanted it to keep happening
then you would be like you're so good at
that
right wait for wait i'm saying a smart
guy
like you're so good at that if they want
it to happen again to get both yeah yeah
so i i was just sort of breaking my own
record of feeling like i'm good at it
by saying wouldn't every guy say that
you're good at it if they wanted you to
do it again
oh even if you i guess if you're like a
biter or something then they certainly
would be like
yo you know what i'm actually not into
it i feel like you'll know if you're
good at it based on
what comes out when it comes out you'll
know like you'll know it's dust right
[Laughter]
just tears stick tears so why um so the
dating the younger guy
yeah how did that go so i would say was
it weird
i would just say no well okay i've never
been into younger guys though because
here's what i'll say he just i just am
like oh what's this
fetish like i assume it's like you don't
really believe that they're not yeah no
no no i'm like oh this you're like
working out something with your mom this
is like a mom
thing he has a thing for julianne moore
though so i actually do believe
that yeah i would know but i'm just i'm
so have so much internalized
misogyny that like i can't because i've
been conditioned to believe that women
as they get older
have no sexual attraction so like why
would a hot
young guy want to date an older woman
when you could date a little thot
right or like yeah with perky boobs and
just like
basically i remember talking to my
friend david o'doherty and he was like
i was like what is it like because he's
a comic too and we were just like
chatting about
being with older women i was like well
what's it like you know like what did
you notice
he's like their skin's just looser and i
was like
it's true like when you touch a body
it's just like their skin's just looser
like that's
it like who really cares oh is it making
you barf i actually liked it
but i just think of pussy right away oh
that's the first thing i think about
that's my nightmare about like
it's a nightmare that a younger guy has
sex with he's like that's like a baggy
pussy
like it's a loose butt i mean all skin
except that
i mean you can't pick and choose which
skin
that goes under that umbrella yeah okay
but that's not actually where i went
you know what else i like about it when
a guy is younger and you're older
i weirdly feel more secure about looking
older
because i'm like this you're this is
your thing yeah he's into it whereas if
i'm dating someone my age i like try to
look younger
sure and like wear makeup and look
perfect but for some reason on him i'm
like you're into this granny shit so
like fucking
i'm not putting makeup on i felt so i i
will say
even though it's not worked out at this
point um
i did feel very comfortable very loved
very confident
yeah like yeah it does take a certain it
takes years maybe to get there with some
people but i was
yeah i was fine like i'd walk around
naked like there was no no there was no
way i needed to
look at your age i really did feel like
loved by him and i and i
love him back i think i just what
happened with us was just maybe
different places in life
yeah and feeling like i've already done
all that i
can't sing along to atlantis morrison
yeah which is really rough
kind of a deal breaker you ought to know
i think you don't know
lisa loeb's songs back not sustainable
but there is a fun part about dating
someone younger because they also kind
of keep you in touch with
younger things like yeah like the memes
the memes they're jiffys and they well
that's
it that believe you said that is when i
started dating a young guy
every text was a picture like a gif
and i know this sounds so fucking old
but like
like i just learned how to communicate
my feelings in words
like last year and now i have to learn a
new language
of like homer simpson should like like
he would like just send me like an
arrested development gift and i'm like i
haven't seen that episode like what
happened
i don't know what this what does do you
want to go to dinner or not and then it
would be like
like little honey boo boo like in a like
child pornography why are you sending me
this i love that like
the giffy the gifts are all like like
there's a lot of funny ones of like
young
girls but we've all agreed it's okay
because
we've all made them famous so it's a
wait they're all the same young girls so
it's okay
like why are you just sending me like
like random gifts of
of babies like children
another aspect of that the communication
like the lots of it did you feel like it
was a lot more than like an older person
like a lot more communication and maybe
potentially on all platforms definitely
like twitter instagram well that kind of
annoyed me because i was like
when i get a dm on instagram i'm like
you have my number why are you doing
this
see it's and i leave it on scene and
it's interesting that you think that
because i'm like
sometimes i like being over there in the
grand i don't know why sometimes it's
like fun to be over
you just like want like a corporation i
have all your text messages forever
yes you just want to make sure jeff
zuckerberg
owns all of your like nudes
i don't do nudes or anything through
this really oh through there oh no 100
what's your like main nude what's the
main go-to nude
i'm someone who's like really worried
about like authenticity and therefore i
can't send like an old
nude because like you had like a speaker
you had like a cute i would feel guilty
like if i sent one to that's old and i
don't look like that anymore
and or that i really sent to someone
else i'm not saying i've never sent the
same one to two people recently
but i am saying like i was in hair and
makeup in this one like that's the same
like one throw the fake filter on it one
time
i think one time i sent an old one and i
wasn't in that bed anymore so i had to
like
make it look like i was still in that
bed i forget what
i'm messing up the whole story if you're
gonna resend this i love you it's my
life but i can't remember you better
make sure you're still in the same
living arrangement yeah they will
eventually be like wait a second
you don't have the same bathroom
[Laughter]
why is barack obama listed as the
president on the background cnn screen
when was this from and you like have to
make up some like
no that was like i took that at a
friend's house you took a nude at a
friend
i flopped the kids
one time my uh a friend of mine got a
dick pic from a guy and it was very
clearly
a cell phone photo of a printed photo
it was so funny like we spent so much
time trying to figure out he printed
that was like his
he had a great dick pic that he
obviously took on like a camera
and he's like this is my pick and then
decided okay
but here's why you got to be careful
about keeping them updated
if they save it to their phone it goes
in chronological order
so that that nude's gonna zip right up
to the top of the camera roll baby
and maybe you hadn't met yet
so that's what i'm gonna advise everyone
here to take a screenshot of whatever
you're gonna send on that day
it is truly the best fucking advice i
have
ever heard i feel like guys must already
know that dude
sending an old nude he's just looking
for it he's like i can't find it
like oh no it's up here with my with my
y2k photos
screenshot and old nude so it doesn't go
to the end of the camera roll
beth hbo max august 20th girl daddy
that is so fucking funny dude i i love
the little ways that uh technology
sabotages
i know fuck i know it does it has
increased
i'm trying to think like obviously it's
helped relationships and getting to know
each other because you can facetime or
you could be with someone who's far away
yeah yeah
get to know them but then yeah it'll get
you it'll get you in the ass all right
well what really gets me is the memories
feature
where it's like a year ago today i want
to see literally it's like
i love the people like oh that was my
baby too i'm like oh like
like like my emotionally abusive ex just
like pops up
ruins my day i don't want to see it look
what are the chances that your memory
from a year ago is going to be a good
one
like i'm just like i'm still on the same
spot thanks for the reminder that i've
made no emotional growth
and also like too i wish you could do
the thing where like
technology will do that to you all the
time like going to text somebody and
it's like suggest the person that you
were talking to for a long time oh wow
like
i know like i don't want to see that
anymore and they don't delete
their contact i guess but that's yeah
that much yeah and then they're gonna
show up first in your instagram stories
yeah it's like
so where are you meeting people online
are you on a dating app
i only did raya like truly for a month
before i met my young boyfriend because
he was canadian
working in that film good boys in canada
yeah and so i
i was with one of the guys on the set
was like you should do
right and i was like okay i'll try it
yeah and then i got into it with that
guy so i
stopped so i i only did that in my whole
life
uh-huh raya for like a month did you
like message with people
i did and i found that
i don't know i match with some people
who never messaged me that's a i think
that's
i think for a lot of guys online it was
like a video game i think all of a
sudden
get as many matches as you can and like
i'll i don't i'll figure out later which
ones i actually want to touch okay
you know yeah yeah that makes sense and
i
i did text with one who who was like oh
i live in i'm gonna burp i think
sorry um like i'm really worried about
how i look from this angle well no
but at the at the beginning it was a
little tight for me um i was like
sitting here like yeah
i know these chairs are uncomfortable
but jesus i know i'm sure i also think i
should
okay um and then i
he was like i live in seattle and this
is what i do and then you can click on
their
social media yeah and i'm not swayed by
like followers i'm not like oh that's
what i want someone with followers
yeah it is sometimes shocking if you
don't know who the person is you have
millions of followers you're like
why what did what yeah what's new shape
were you in yeah or
or like what what like what like you
would eat i just don't know what niche
granola bar
did you invent or something exactly or
it's like a i'm trying to think what it
was like a photographer for
house magazine that's not a magazine but
yeah i just mean
home and homing i better go i feel like
um i feel like you're just glitching
it's just
like the spinning wheel from the
computer is over your face
and then there was one guy who was in
like a band again like kind of a more
red flag yeah
so and i think maybe it was just like hi
hi what's up yeah
yeah and i'm not kidding that means no
and there's honestly i
truly when someone messages me on a
dating app after three texts it's like
great wanna hop or three messages wanna
hop to text
and then i would like to move to
facetime
oh you facetime love a facetime
love of facebook oh love a facetime i'm
not against it
i'm not oh i'm so pro facetime it's
ridiculous because
number one i can see the inside of their
home you can see if they have a good
wi-fi connection if your wi-fi sucks
that is a red flag to me your shit's
just not in order
like you're just not on point with your
life yeah and then i get to see your
house right away because i don't if
anyone else is in it
that's exactly right pan around run
around there's just
a girlfriend in the corner i'm moving
out soon
i was dating a guy who was a rock
climber and i was like pan to the
ceiling i know you did girls at a rock
climber
girl hanging from the ceiling like a
spider um
but there are some people i usually i
think
people like us find them usually if you
meet someone who's like boring like
my reaction to someone neurochemically i
usually can tell
what they are you know i'm like this
person's an alcoholic this person is a
codependent this person is a love addict
sex addict whatever
adrenaline addict narcissist borderline
what would narcissist clues be
narcissist instantly you start walking
on eggshells yes
instantly you start complimenting them
oh my god that's how you know you're
dealing with a narcissist oh my god yeah
yeah so you can usually tell what's
going on with someone else based on your
reaction to them narcissism i make
myself smaller
that's what happens i start
self-deprecating again not with a young
man just to be clear yeah i start
self-deprecating i start minimizing
myself
i start like like yes not shining it's
not really comfortable
or confident and then it made me feel
yeah not feeling comfortable confident
it made me feel liking everything i say
i'll say something i'm like that was
dumb you shouldn't have said that
i shouldn't have said that and then i
start
cleaning up the mess with my codependent
people pleasing behaviors i'm like do
you need anything
then i become a waitress and i'm like do
you need anything are you hungry do you
want anything like is it cold like do
you want to again i start like giving
them things
i'm just sort of like yes these
headphones do you want them like you
could totally use these
it's like what just recently happened to
me yeah i was just like
i also too was bummed because i was like
you don't ask me any questions about
myself like
i wish you would try to get to know me
so you can understand me because right
now i'm spiraling
i didn't say this but i feel like i'm
walking on eggshells and stuff and if i
weren't feeling like that then i'd be
myself and you
see how great i am yeah and then so
unfortunately instead of like
being grounded and remembering that i'm
the adult and i can take care of things
in myself and i don't have to
like yeah you know receive that yeah i
instead did most of those things
that's really interesting and did you
feel it right away uh no because it was
kind of like fun at first
yeah absolutely because i yeah i by the
way i am so gravitated i
i it gives me i it recreates my
childhood circumstances perfectly it's a
comfort zone for me it's certainly the
beginning i get the perfect
neurochemical cocktail of adrenaline and
cortisol and shame and guilt and
eggshell walking and like hated it oh
god but then i i
i so sickly love it because when you do
get their approval it's like
you're right bread crumbs almost like
like yeah or you're trying to like
he did say this and he didn't he did
that maybe he does like and he hates
everyone else
yeah and he's so hard to please and i
pleased him
but here's this this is the thing now
and maybe this is not your part
then i'm thinking to myself i don't like
this person they're kind of negative
like i don't want to be with this type
of person
yet and i decide that and i draft up my
i think we should stop talking like you
know 15 with 15 different alts
yes or a text just in my notes app
because it's like i might need to be
able to say hey so i'm going to practice
with all your apologies yeah along with
like you know i don't think it's working
but i think we should stop talking
and you know yeah and i never send it
and then the minute he's like yeah i
want to do this tonight
i'm there yeah you know like why would i
like you know
and then i'm hurt at the ready yeah i
don't know and then it's just like and
then i'm
there's something very i couldn't cut it
off why wouldn't i be able to just
cut it off there's something very
cellular
about narcissists in the way they have
control over us
because i think it recreates an
authority figure which is children we
figure out how to please our parents and
make them like you know
and they say narcissists can get really
specific there's different kinds of
narcissists they say that
narcissists project the image that their
parents would have approved of
they themselves projected yes so for
example if someone's like i'm amazing at
sports i'm fucking amazing at basketball
i'm the best basketball player in the
fucking planet you're like oh your dad
wanted you to be an athlete
i see and you couldn't do it and now
you're projecting the image that he
would have approved of
like it can get pretty specific you know
and
i'm like oh i just learned everything
your parents didn't
like absolutely based on what you're now
projecting you have to project an image
of the person they would have loved wow
in the
whatever so i i don't sympathize with
narcissists like there are some neural
wiring things and like
um where they just lack empathy for
other people and they have to be the
center of attention at all times like
like someone where if you're having a
conversation and talking about your day
and you're like oh then i got in a car
accident and i
i hit this person's bumper and they're
like well when i got
in a fender bender four years ago and my
seat belt didn't work and you're like
not the same thing why are you now
making this about you how did you manage
to make that about you
yeah you know and when you feel the need
to take care of their feelings all the
time
is a big one and but when you're
describing that type sometimes it
doesn't even mean that they're like
really that animated or the center of
attention necessarily
it can just be more of like a narcissist
can be very charming and very
charismatic
which is a red flag in a lot of ways but
they also can be very withholding
yeah so that they give only 10 so you're
giving 90.
and then you give so much you still
don't get the approval that you need
which even if you got it you it's impo
you can't hold on for a long time it
wasn't like enough yeah i didn't i
could never really quench it's
insatiable
but narcissists love for someone to do
90 and for them to do 10.
wow yeah and then because you get to do
the shame
spiral yourself because then you're like
why did i give so much it's like
codependence breeds resentment thing but
unrecovered codependents we
love narcissists because they make us
feel like shit
interesting and you can never get their
approval so you're in this constant
approval seeking process
and the process like reaffirms this old
false narrative then i'm not good enough
so i am i know i'm good enough i'm
enough
yeah i'm gonna find someone that
no fault of their own makes me feel like
it's like cutting or something it's like
i'm gonna hurt myself
yeah like i'm just hurting myself with
you yeah and i think sometimes too like
when you're talking i was like ugh i
worry sometimes that i'm like i'm that
and i might be that i might be like you
can read a horoscope and be like it's
true that's right that's right
we're all everything so yeah because
when you were talking about that i'm
like oh no sometimes when somebody's
sharing something i give them my
experience you know like and i don't
mean to make it about me but that's how
i'm trying to relate to you like oh that
happened to me too but it's your mo it's
all motives
yeah so and you can feel motive so it's
like if i talk about the car accident i
just got in you're like oh my god i did
that and the insurance of this
you're relating to me that's one thing
if we're attuning to each other
but if someone's just like well when
this happened like spotlight back on me
yeah yeah feel the difference you can
totally feel me yeah it's not about
commiserating it's just about
um i just don't want to hear your
experience like i've had
dismissive yeah it's dismissive i think
we know so much
like sometimes obviously like you you
hear psychologists
in their own trauma and you know why
they became that thing yeah
you know yeah um because they have their
own i don't want to call it baggage but
their own trauma or own experiences or
something
and so i was like thinking about that
where i'm just like um
i don't know i don't want to be the pro
oh i think it's a comic is where i was
going with that
it's like you need to be able to joke
about it to make it
maybe have your power over it or have it
make sense in your head yeah in order to
joke about it you have to like become an
expert on it yeah
that's what i find myself doing
interesting sometimes i get so
bothered and ignored like everything you
shared with me would have been like new
information for me because i haven't
delved into the narcissist and thing i
have an idea of what it is but when you
shared all those things i was like
now is there anybody in rage with that
person yeah they discussed that they had
had it in the past yeah
but oh that's such a fucking narcissist
move to list all their flaws
they will say like i did this and here's
all the things i did write it
up so then moving now you know
everything yeah
you know you know what you're signing up
for yeah what kind of piece of shit
would sign up for this
and when i fuck up like i told you
i told you i was yeah i'm a mess yeah i
told you i was like this
yeah it's a i'm a superior piece of shit
or something it's like i'm better than
you because not only am i self-aware
but i'm going to tell you all my flaws
so number one you like weirdly respect
me for being self-aware and
by litany of shit now you know what's
coming and i don't have to be a good
person
and i'm like and i would like to gift
you this rug
but i think sometimes we really conflate
self-awareness with sickness
it's not when people like i have this i
have this i'm like whoa they're so brave
and they're so vulnerable and like
they they know they've done work on
themselves but it's also like are you
walking the walk
yeah you're like you have awareness now
now the change thing like when people
like i hate it when guys go like well
i'm a guy i'm dumb like i'm gonna do
dumb i'm like
you're not a brawny commercial i mean
but like when someone's like well i have
this and i have depression and i have
this and it's just sort of like
okay now you are making it so i can't
apply the same rules to you
yeah like you're coding yourself an
invincibility of your own self-awareness
so now yeah i see i'm not allowed to
treat you like an adult
yeah and sort of or hold you responsible
for things like
it's like they're whatever um it's like
a medical issue like
here's your note for gems so you don't
have to write mine also don't give
yourself the note i'm going to give you
don't take that away from me don't let
me say it
let me leave you that yell preview yeah
it's like i'm just a dumb guy that's
what i was going to say
don't steal my lines don't steal my
insults
but yeah sometimes when people sort of
beat themselves up there's this instinct
to go like oh they're so evolved and
like you know like i talk to girlfriends
all the time they're like you know that
he's really
working on his shit i'm like why is
there so much shit to work on
yeah working on the shit still means
they have a bunch of shit
and working on it you know what i mean
yeah
how hard are they working talking about
it to other people isn't working on it
it's true you're not working on it if
you're just telling everyone
about your trauma it doesn't count yeah
and i've always found too like
i think sometimes people who have like
you know you never want to be the person
that has been through stuff
and then uses it as an excuse for your
behavior you know
yes victimizing yourself is a form of
like bullying sometimes yeah i was like
this isn't going to go over well but
um i was thinking about this the other
day such a weird look oh i was just
thinking like this isn't going to go
with the world i was like the comment
section yeah male comics are like oh i'm
fucked up because like
my dad my p i watch my parents fight and
female comments were like i'm fucked up
because uh
my dad fucked me you know what i mean
like it's like there's like so
i mean that's not true by the way sorry
dad um i'm just saying like there's
sometimes it feels like yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're a little bit like okay
i'm sorry you had to say that trust me
i'm not trying to compare
like yes yes that's why i said it wasn't
going to go over well
yeah no it it it's no i'm trying to
figure out
because i'm having so many reactions
versus females male versus female tear
me apart truly built my house
men and women is why i get to live here
so i'm not
against it that's fully my brand i do
one of my favorite jokes from that
special was the um what do they call it
a backup dancer i don't want to ruin the
joke i wish you could oh yeah what was
that
so i know i just i didn't want to give
the punch what i had to do backup dancer
i did have a backup dancer joke in the
last special i don't remember what it
was i do remember the idea which is why
i'm laughing but i kept doing a backup
yeah
i truly can't remember i after i shoot a
special i like
it's like the black box i know that gets
removed there are male gold diggers too
they're called black backup dancers
that's a good joke
okay guys ritual ritual now i don't read
the ads because i'm whitney
this is mine these are my drinks
and i don't read the ads guys i don't
read the ads
because i'm authentic i'm real
i'm new and different but also true to
form
ritual benton whitney do i take these
every day
do i take these vitamins every day you
do you ask every day
you actually do take vitamins there's
photos on the internet me taking them
probably
listen every day i take these vitamins
ritual ritual is
great it's an essential vitamin for
women it's a multivitamin but it's
reimagined it comes right to your door
there's no more
there's no more going going outside
getting in a car
driving i don't i don't i refuse to
drive
i refuse and ritual makes it easy
there's none of that that flavor
that flavor that i can't mention there's
none of it because they don't use it
there's like a mint there's
a minty tab in there there's a minty tab
rich was essential for even look at the
computer it has d3
omega-3 um it fills in all the gaps in a
woman's diet and as you know
we we we spend a lot of time running
around
doing things for you so you don't die of
a sinus infection
so this is great better health doesn't
happen overnight and right now
ritual is offering my listeners 10 off
during your first three months
fill in the gaps in your diet with
essentials for women a small step that
helps support a healthy
foundation for your body visit
ritual.com
whitney that's what i do
to start your ritual today that's 10 off
during your first three months at
ritual.com
whitney
where's my daily harvest uh here it is
it's my daily harvest
daily harvest daily harvest they come
i'm not reading the ad i don't need to
read the ad i've never had to read an ad
i ate these every day
these bananas spinach cacao
cashew peppermint this is a smoothie
that i drink
can you stop shaking it so that it makes
so much noise
how dare you embarrass me in front of my
fans
daily harvest is delivered right to your
door i love delivery had this necklace
delivered diamond to a headband from
etsy
these scoops are available i can't i
can't these scoops are available from
daily harvest they're free of additives
preservatives and fillers
they're made from you know what you know
what i love you know what i love about
daily harvest let me tell you what i
love about it is that you
if you're in a rush you can just you can
just eat this product
open this yeah
to blend it you don't even have to
this is spinach
i thought that was the mint cacao one
how fresh is it though tell her it is so
if i took this down my mouth it would
just be a perfect piece of spinach
daily harvest is a lifesaver i'm truly
i'm truly living off of it right now i'm
alive because of daily harvest
there are tons of options any time of
day they have smoothies harvest bowls
flatbreads flatbreads
that's a thin piece of bread
my favorite one is the smoothie the mint
cacao
i like the dressing i also love the
dragon fruit fruit i love i've mentioned
it
probably 15 times i still don't know
what dragon fruit love
that one love it love it there's there's
granola in it there's little pieces of
granola in it
and i love it also because i'm real
because i don't tell lies keep it simple
this summer with daily harvest go to
dailyharvest.com and enter promo code
good for you
to get 25 off your first box that's
promo code good for you
for 25 off your first box at
dailyharvest.com
dailyharvest.com your only child
are you an olympian i mean basically
okay because with sisters i bring it up
because it's like i have older sister
older brother and then a bunch of
siblings i've never met
um but i was just saying you have older
sisters they kind of just i'm not saying
my sister's trapped me in the past but
i'm just saying
you know though it's kind of one of
those they don't do that at all i'm just
saying no we talk about this all the
time
your family makes you regress and stay
stuck in the role you were cast in when
you were like 15
and you don't get to grow and the people
in your family you come home and you
have to regress
back to that power dynamic of like and
i've had this with friends too
where it's like i'm the younger kid that
they make fun of and beat up on and
and then 10 years later i'm like don't
talk to me like that yeah
i'm an adult i'm 37 years old like don't
call me a cunt or a hooker
don't say hey hooker i do hate that yeah
i hate it
i had a girlfriend growing up that was
like what's up or yeah slut maybe
what's up sluts what what i just didn't
ever really like it maybe it was playful
but always felt a little hateful
uh hooker hey whore hooker was one yeah
hooker is
it's just it's honestly i mean
i think you hate me why are you here
why are you like cat calling me this is
supposed to be a safe space
hooker i kind of miss the word hooker
that i don't like when
girls call me hooker but since you know
there's a conversation about like sex
work now
oh yeah it's people say prostitute and
sex worker and i'm like i kind of miss
hooker
yeah that's such a like rough one it
feels very julia roberts
like holy woman there's something just
like hookers this is a good word
yeah because it's just kind of like like
it also makes you feel like you got them
on the line you know like yeah it's like
you're in charge like yeah
like hooker is just i'm it's such a
weird there's a plosive there with a k
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah it's it's a
good word i don't
i don't like when yeah i don't like when
girls
use words on each other they don't like
it the guys use on them you know what i
mean
i get why guys are a little confused i
wouldn't yeah i would never
they're like don't talk to me like that
hey honker and they're like wait so what
am i
hey
yeah i don't like yeah i've never found
um it
okay it sounds silly to be like
appropriate but i've never found it
appropriate to call a friend
any sort of name yeah i'm not saying
i've never gotten a fight i can't think
of anything
specifically i actually maybe like she's
being a bitch
but i would say that to our other friend
about her yeah here's the thing i
think i can't call women because
in work environments i say sweetheart
i said sweet pea for a while yeah this
is more of a southern thing
this is more of my opinion virginia did
this sweet pea honey
is a big one i like honey honey but when
natasha calls me honey like i feel good
about myself
yeah yeah but if a guy called you honey
you'd be like
yeah i mean like tricky yeah freaky yeah
so like i'm thinking of like being in
the writer's room of
another period and like if when natasha
did it it was lovely and if moshe was
like hey honey i'd be like but natasha's
from the 20s
i have to get her registered because she
doesn't even know she has the legal
right
i mean natasha is like of a different
era yes it's true you know
but yeah i i i'm trying to think if i've
had like a a boss say honey
if it was an older man i'm trying to
think of somebody that you've been in i
feel like we've been a lot of similar
work situations
and it's interesting the things you have
to normalize or go numb to
like are there so where you're just like
okay your hand was a little low on my
back that hug was just a little too long
but like what am i gonna say something
yeah what am i going to be the squeaky
wheel
oh i mean definitely in the past 100
that attitude
like i felt like just hang like just be
cool just deal with it
because it's also the kind of thing
where it's like when you explain it it
does
sound dramatic yeah i get like and i
think being
told you're crazy your psycho calm down
relax for so long
has been internalized in my when it's
like and then it's also like
for me to go to hr is like it's like an
hour out of my day and like i have to
fill out a bunch of forms
and like that's why i found it so funny
in in burr special when he's talking
about how angry it was that another
female comic flip
flicked his dick yeah it well my
takeaway from that because he was so
upset he talked about meditating on it
like he made it into a bit yeah
yeah enough to be a bit yeah i could
have all those bits
yeah so many of those yes but it was
like i'll be cool i'll hang because it's
in chicago and
back in the room and i didn't keep it a
secret because i was ashamed i was like
yeah
why what what is it going to get me if i
don't come to the show anymore it's the
best show in the city
yeah so the anger i understood his anger
and i related to it because i was like
yeah that's the
closest you'll understand what it's like
to be a female comic guy yeah yeah but
it's all
or a woman in any business sure sure i
mean i'm only speaking from my own
experience right right i speak for all
women
um everyone everyone knows that i've
been elected there was a there was a
meeting there was like
yeah there was a series of oh my god
i've been chosen to spoke
for all but it's like the little tiny
things where it's like
the bigger things like someone slapping
you on the ass or something is
almost better because at least it's
clear what happened
i know what i whereas when it's
something just kind of ooky and creepy
and we're like i'm
cornered or something where i'm like i'm
not sure if i'm crazy
yeah cause uh and if i
explained it to someone i would probably
sound like either one i was
like bragging yeah or overreacting
or um uh think quite a lot of myself
sure you know what i mean i know like i
just feel like he hugs me like a little
too long like okay
easy right like take the comments but
it's sad because all those things you
just said are just stuff that's thrown
at us when we say like hey
i this happened and i didn't like it now
yeah do this for a time by the way i
just don't
yeah exactly you know what i mean i love
this attention i love sitting in a
i love everyone hating me because i had
self-respect i wrote down for some
reason in my word document of questions
for you
what is your experience with gaslighting
you know what's interesting my therapist
just said that to me on
wednesday what yeah that he he was
gassing you and i was like
it would you know what's interesting i
had a i had a reaction to it like almost
like i don't love all the rape culture
terms they kind of
make me feel i guess like judged and
ashamed like i was triggered like
well that's true but i feel weird saying
it because everybody like jokes about
people being social justice warriors and
very sensitive yeah yeah yeah
so when you say gaslit i'm almost
ashamed to like
say it the guy was gas little and i'm
sure about it because i'm like i don't
know oh i get psyched to say it because
then i'm like okay that wasn't my fault
i was tricked you fooled me once
i feel way less stupid when i'm like oh
they gaslight me thank god
so what did that mean for you though
when you say they gaslight me
gaslighting is
when and my um someone told me to watch
the movie gaslight which is a very maybe
i need a white
it's an old black and white movie that
kind of just like
so that you're not like reading an
annoying clinical book about gaslighting
it just shows basically when you're in a
bad relationship it can be with a boss
it can be with co-workers family members
gaslight
a lot it kind of masquerades as
codependence and undercover alcoholism
and stuff but
it's when a crazy person makes you think
you're the crazy one
so um start a fight with me
i wanted you to stay for coffee
okay i just i i don't know why you're
yelling at me oh i wasn't yelling i said
i
like i just feel like you're attacking
me and i just i like it just hurts
when you well now you're like do you
feel angry at me really no well now
you're laughing you're smiling
now you're laughing at me so i just now
i'm hurt
you know the answer is yes i'd love to
have coffee with you
but it's like sort of when somebody
victimizes themselves to the
i love how you said shared a fight with
me and i was like would you like to have
coffee
i know that was weird i didn't know what
to fight about no but it's like
gaslighting is very like the person will
victimize themselves usually when they
are the perpetrators it's like when
classic okay when someone who's cheating
on you accuses you of cheating okay to
like
throw you off so that you're like no no
i'm not cheating it didn't ever so that
you're showing
them your phone so that you're not
looking at theirs okay it's a way to
sort of
gaslight you into thinking you're the
problem wow you know
and a lot of people gaslight with like
psychology
jargon like of like we know too much
now yes it's like some people will
manipulate
self-help book jargon in order to just
like be like well now this is just my
attachment strategy and i'm
fearful of voiding and you're attacking
me so i'm going and i'm triggered and
like they'll use it these are my love
languages totally
so they like appear really healed and
stuff and it makes you feel like you're
crazy
wow and like well they've done some work
so i guess i'm yeah
you know silent treatment is is
gaslighty
and yeah you know withholding is
gaslighting withholding love
punishing yeah like or ass yeah so i
guess i said coffee because it was like
i'm gonna stay for coffee and i'm like
yeah and then like i start talking
like i just wanted to like chill out
and not this how you fight have you
talked about this really quiet talking
oh okay sorry
i'm saying this this is the scariest way
to fight with someone
can't believe you just did that it's
such a weird like serial killer fucking
you just get super no
i'm what i did i'm like i'm sorry i
don't know why
you're doing this you just turned into
john rivers
i actually think though when i fight i
get tired argue
and i say i don't i'm not fighting you
i'm fighting for you
i'm not fighting with you i'm fighting
for you and if i win we both lose
that's kind of gaslighting i
one time uh was talking about like you
know when you've been together with them
for a long time
and you know their stories mm-hmm you
see them tell their story
you know what i'm trying to have had
that happen i don't think i have been
with anybody like like
long enough oh when you but i know what
you're saying when someone's got a story
that's like a great story and it's like
tell the story and they tell it at
dinner and you've heard it a bunch of
times and you're like oh
god like that's how i feel sometimes
about stand-up comedy though
well we do that for a living right now
like if
truly is a huge part of me
losing attraction to people is watching
them tell the same story at dinner
parties over and over again you'd be
like you fucking hack oh by the way you
changed that story that's not even how
it fucking happened oh you just like
punched it up like
oh all of a sudden now you're driving
yeah all of a sudden you're in italy for
the story for a reason like all like
yeah i wouldn't like that either why
does your story keep getting better
every time you tell him why do you get
more heroic
every time you tell the story and like
you know when you're at a dinner party
and you see a couple
telling a story and the wife's like
that's not what happened yes
you're like oh that's not what happened
there's nothing worse
than when someone in a couple calls out
the other person for lying in a store
no it's true and it is like it could be
so uncomfortable but you just like think
of her
being like that was that was cool to
call it out yeah i'm like well you're
breaking up soon
like i'm glad to be a part of your
journey um of your separation but no i
think
love is letting them tell the story
letting them shine
letting them lie a little bit laughing
at it and saying fucking nothing
you don't get to embarrass your person
in public i don't care i don't care 100
yeah unless of course they're being like
drunk and ridiculous or something then
you're like
we need to leave i'm sorry everyone we
need to leave and get married
immediately we have to leave we have to
go we're moving in together
i love you too much and don't want to
share you and
uh one time a friend of mine told me
this uh story about he's
been with his girl for like 20 years oh
my god
they're married with kids i know okay
wow i'm just trying to make like
figure out a way to where when he's
listening to this he doesn't know it's
him um
and he has a story a like crazy story
about when like he was in germany and
like he had this big fight with like
some
criminal and it was like like he got
burgled would you call it mugged
and he told the story so many times that
and
and one time she they were to dinner and
she started telling the story as if it
had happened to her
and she starts like killing with this
door no in the car and he's like that
didn't happen
like what was that and she's like what
do you mean he's like that didn't happen
to me and she's like no it didn't
like no he was like you stole my story
she's like i don't know where you and
and i begin i think that's just so
funny i can't believe that and you're
just like i don't need like when you see
a couple trying to tell a story
and it's like and then we were no go
like
when you see a couple like and then no
that's not exactly what no no you do it
like
i just love that you see two couples
trying not like a couple trying to win
the dinner party
they're both competing with each other
and you're like this is gonna be such a
big fight in the car oh my god
i need to go to more dinner parties i've
been to one and it was that was in the
before
yeah that's true um i have more i are
you on birth control i have written down
here
um is that an inappropriate question no
i have jokes about it of course i'm not
in birth control because sometimes birth
control is like i know you're hungry but
what if you cried
you know so i don't
i got an audible
two men in the room were bummed out and
men love birthdays
you managed to ruin birth control for
two men yeah i don't do that i did the
pill for a bit
yeah and one i it was in college and i'm
trying to remember
what was collagen well no in college
sorry in college what color was the
thing um yeah it was blue i mean the the
outsman
yeah maybe that's yes yes ortho
tricyclin's pink yeah it was the blue
yeah and then i stopped that i got the
marina iud i have it um
and i had that for i kept obviously the
first one for five years because that's
how long it lasts
and then i got another one so much when
you put it in um
yeah it didn't feel good it hurt the i
have a very high tolerance for pain not
emotional physical
and i like truly not bra it's i i broke
my shoulder didn't go to the doctor for
three days like i
pain is like for whatever reason i have
a very high tolerance for pain
got the iud i puked wow
i first of all when it got installed yes
got inserted when it got sewn in
stitched
whatever i flew back so hard i hit my
head on the wall
and the guy and i was just like are you
like you could have a concussion like i
had to sit down and they did all the
concussion stuff
and then i puked and it was the most
it was the it's a weird pain yeah
they said did he say this to you it's
going to feel like one big contraction
did they say that oh no i mean i've
never had a kid so how was i
yeah yeah totally no reference it felt
it was truly the
the worst pain yeah it to me it was like
like that and then also like it you know
it was like a stabbing in a place i've
never been touched which means every guy
yeah
dick i'm learning a lot as i talk
through the jabbed but
at my cervix a couple times until it
finally figured out its way the penis
sorry keep the iud no um to
just my cervix it hurt real bad like ow
like wait with a dick yeah and then it
found its way but
anyway wait is my vagina deformed i'm
i've learned i actually found that i
have a
a by horn uterus which is why i don't
have that marina anymore
what's a bihorn uterus you could look at
it one of two ways depending on how you
feel about me
one would be that it's heart-shaped
and two would be like it's like a devil
devil shaped it's a i've been told so
many things about my uterus
it's a type of malerian anomaly in the
human uterus where there's a deep
indentation at the fundus of the uterus
i don't even know i had a fundus you
have a fundus i don't like that an
operative word fun
well they told me it was like this is
this rare
i don't know uh it's about point
four percent of people have this well i
was told that
we're very special and that i shouldn't
continue with the marina because i could
get pregnant in one side
okay yeah so it's like i could get it
could be over here
wow so you would need you have like two
uteruses
i don't even know about that because
it's definitely seen you're a uterus
hoarder
yeah so you have a heart-shaped uterus
that's so
sweet so the tea would have been in
there but yeah so when guys are fucking
you're fucking like a heart it's even
weirder and darker fall in love with me
that was gross don't break my arm
that's so weird so you don't do the
mirena that is
your heart-shaped uterus yeah and also i
mean
do we want to get graphic because i
can't what are we doing i'm saying like
the strings that hang out
um i guess it depends on like here's why
the strings that hang out of the iud yes
yeah so like
for i'm sure most people who are
watching i would imagine no but it's
like you have your
uterus there's the that's the uh cervix
here which
if you're it feels like to see an enemy
type hole you know like you if you
reached up in there that's
okay you just ruined vaginas for me
forever the same enemy
i'm saying is that the only thing that
feels like that and then you would have
to reach
a little bit you're like okay
you're like so the octopus asshole like
like can we find a different point of
view
calamari yeah tiny little tiny tiny
little donut
so you know the iud goes in the vagina
and then
up through the cervix into your uterus
yeah
and so the strings hang out the cervix
and obviously they don't hang out your
vagina like a tampon would no
but if you're in there you could feel
the strings they feel almost like a
little bit of fishing
line that's right that's right like and
sometimes they a guy will be like it
poked my penis and they they think
that's because they have another way
first of all congratulations
but it's most sticks slide right past
the cervix it doesn't mean you have a
big peen if
it poked your your d really yeah
it's just at an angle yeah i'm realizing
i don't know
what a cervix is i mean like i don't
know how different i don't really know
about it i don't know
anyway what a vagina is versus a uterus
for i know
that difference like cervix like maybe
i had a what was it called huh a
spurgeon yes
uh you're that's my friend's life by
corey no remember you said i have like
a gurgle oh a fun funness but
[Laughter]
no it's uh i don't know okay the graphic
stuff i was going to say was more like
say you are with a partner who is um
jizzing in you do you like how it was
like searching for a word that would be
first of all i also
i get weirdly shy around the stuff i
don't pussy i really don't like it okay
sorry about that no it's okay
i'm just telling you i don't know what i
say for
chisel drizz what did you call it jizz
yeah i don't
i like it weirdly like calm is the thing
i get
okay i get shy about this like i stephen
okay demon is very critical i like okay
so if he's seamanizing you
[Music]
[Laughter]
you ejaculate it you have to think like
obviously you want to maybe go to the
restroom afterwards like it's not
fully necessary but that's a good idea
and then also oh it's fully necessary
but you're right
pee the second after you have sex i mean
run like the wind
avoid that uti yeah there's that yeah
but we're gonna have jobs now we have a
place to be
go pee after sex you don't need to sit
there and snuggle while like
a fucking like a jelly doughnut
just oozing out of you onto your nice
sheer sheets are too nice and your time
is too valuable
pee after sex and as you're peeing like
obviously if you were with someone that
you trusted and you let them
semonize you then that would come out
too so all i'm saying is the strings are
experiencing all of that
and over time for me i felt like
they were coated in crystallized colors
yeah and someone who i wasn't compatible
with
and therefore i believe sometimes
someone's you're not compatible with i
think sometimes they're just can
curdle in your place
[Music]
i'm just trying to find the right gis
you're telling me that you got your id
room because of
over the years i just felt bad jizz was
collecting on the stream it tainted
the string but it was like instead of
watching that man right out of my hair
i was washing his jizz right off my
stream right so you were carrying the
jizz of past lovers around with you
you know like a little bit and then
and then and then
yeah and then i also was dealing with
face stuff like my face was breaking out
and i thought
maybe it is because it felt like maybe
it cleared up my face initially
and controlling college because i think
a lot of people think birth control
clears up your face
hormone because you i mean again the one
that i'm on you don't really have your
period so you don't get the hormonal
acne i used to get hormonal acne along
my jawline
yeah and now that i kind of skip you're
on the marina
marina yeah yeah yeah because i get such
bad migraines i i
having periods like i get such migraines
here's the thing i consider going back
but then
like i told i said i recently found out
it was bi by horned or whatever
yeah before that i had a different gyno
back home in dayton
say that i stayed in ohio yes that my
uterus was tilted that was one of my
earlier jokes like so even my uterus is
like
yeah yeah yeah so it's like lean back i
was told it was tilted then i'm told
it's by horn i'm over here just like
tilted uterus doesn't it that feels like
science that
expired yeah that feels like it was a
thing
it was awesome we were wrong and i guess
how would she even know if it wasn't an
uh ultrasound or something if she's just
well your body what if you're just
yeah maybe you're not bending over
enough
why is my uterus broken because you're
come to me you have a bad back yeah
it's just sort of like i don't tilted
uterus feels a little bit like a
we just it's a scam it feels like a scam
it just feels like there's nothing wrong
and i need to give you a fake problem
yeah
oh so then i did get it yanked one time
so
on the second one i had it for five
years get to get
get it yanked going to get the new one
it goes in
truly the worst way to describe what's
happening she says whoops
i didn't do it right yanks the second
one out
here we go for a third one in so i was
in there just getting
plunged you know what i mean wait wait
wait you've said colonel you said
plunging
how do we find synonyms
the removal was done the insertion
wait i'm confused she pulled the so so
first three
years is done those years have passed
and i got a lot done
and then you mean that iud was put to
good use yes okay
yeah i was just covered in ropes of gum
i always say it was the number one
birthday or wait what i have a joke
about it i can't remember
something like the birth number one
birth control player of the year
well i i forget fair something like this
and so then i get it
removed removed i'm ready for my new one
yeah she goes to put it in
says something like whoop sorry that
didn't go in great or something
and maybe didn't far enough or i don't
know removes it
yanks and has to do the new one again
because of your
tilted ass uterus i guess i don't know
so that was maybe
who knows four years still in no that's
been taken out so then i got that
removed
because i was worried about my face
about breaking out yeah what's your skin
what do you do to your skin because it's
very good
i'm breaking out okay i mean i mean
you're the one who we're all always
breaking out yeah that's just a given
this is a population right now
everyone's always breaking out
yeah and especially around the mouth for
me i'm breaking out so much because of
number one being on my phone all the
time because we're never in person when
you hold your phone you're fucking your
phone is just
covered it is a petri dish of funk and
then
the masks wearing masks outside i'm so
broken out yeah this is
yeah so now i do what do i do purpose
face wash try to know when but spot
treatment
oh that's like what the doctor you
recommended me gave it to me okay
um it's retinoid i guess okay got it got
it yes
but it's not on each set it is or is it
i could do a thin layer if i wanted
everywhere because it actually supposed
to help with wrinkles or something but
these aren't going anywhere so i think
like there's i just do spot treatment on
it yeah
and then i do my sister is a sells
beauty counter
oh no i love their eyeshadows yeah i i
just said i'm using that oh yeah yeah
yeah
so my sister sells beauty counter and i
use i pick and choose like i cherry pick
what i like
yeah um but so i use their uh there's
something that is a
when i was breaking out a lot there is a
product called arcania
arc oh you might have told me about that
now i need to definitely get it it was
like overnight cleared up breakouts it's
prescription
but it when i break out around my face i
used that for a while and it really
worked
okay you know yeah the trent noins like
seems to be working pretty you know what
else really worked for me
she is i'm sorry
what word no i don't let guys come on my
face
i mean i feel like i've done it once
just to give it away
i'm just like i'm good oh i had the
sorry i almost called him out but i
i've definitely gotten accidentally just
in the eye and it stinks
really bad by the way the the the one
comment like i told you i did
it no you actually i'd go to a pharmacy
at like two in the morning and get
fucking visine because i had fucking
come in my eye
yeah come in the eye dang no oh
i don't underst also a couple things
number one
i don't need you to come on my if you
need that
right fine i just i'm past the point
where i can like walk to the bathroom
with my head back because i'm trying to
not drip you know what i mean i have
things i care about now
and i have a home when i had a shitty
apartment i was fine but i just like i
value my sheets too much and number two
i was just talking to a guy that i was
hooking up with about this i was like if
you want to come on my face that's fine
but you are running the risk
if you miss you look like such a pussy
and you do not get any tickets or a
prize yeah you just like
if you better fucking stick the landing
because if you miss and it's like in my
hair and like you're just gonna look
like an idiot it is
just so interesting like you better slam
dunk that shit because i will lose
respect for you if it's a bad
like weird splatter and also it better
be
it it better be a lot because then i'm
like
i don't want to be measuring how much
cum came out because then i'm like why
is it like
are you jerking off in the morning then
i'll start doing math on your semen
this is all true is this weird no i mean
i like that you're being open about it
it's not like weird it's i'm just saying
like don't
vary you know right in size yeah but
i mean this is your baby isn't there
like an old wives and
torque uh isn't there an old wives tale
this might be true
that i i remember seeing this like on
vh1 or something like a musician's wife
was saying
they always made their man like pull out
when they came home to make sure they
weren't cheating to see how much come
they had but
oh that's fine so save it all for me no
whether it's true or not if i
see your comment it's not a lot i'm like
did you just jerk off like that is very
interesting i know they also age
sometimes and prostate
yeah makes a diff oh does it yeah age
and prostate
yeah it's also like i i understand the
allure of
like we're so wild i'm to come on your
face but like the second it's over it's
just like it's such
was it that fuck how could it be that
great now and
is the greatness in it hurting my eye
we're taking a little break from beth
stelling to tell you about article which
is
truly truly my favorite furniture benton
do i love this furniture
how much did you order how much do we
have we ordered it it's coming
um this sunday we have eight pieces it's
my favorite furniture
my whole outside article comfortable
easy to build
easy to build easy to they bring it to
your door
contactless delivery i don't even see
the person
i'm authentic article combines the
curation of a boutique furniture store
with the comfort and simplicity of on
shopping online how would you describe
articles design
i would say how about how would you
describe articles design really how
would you describe it i would say it's
like a no i know you're talking but i
would say
i would say it's like a it's like a
mid-century
modern like swedish bohemian
like very it's just good you know like
when furniture is just like
you know when it's good you know when
furniture is just like good
that's what it is articles oh what did
you ask me
do you want to answer the question you
asked you what what let us know
what i just i just was going to say it's
a very clean design
yeah clean is good it is clean you're
right that's good yeah clean
uh you know fresh modern timeless i'd
say
timeless timeless is a good word
timeless that's a word i use a lot
classic is a good word you think that's
a good word that's a good that is a good
word uh we're gonna
i thought i thought you're gonna say
something crazy but honestly you nailed
it you really did you nailed it
um fair prices you save up to 30 over
traditional retail prices article is
able to keep their prices low by cutting
out the middle man
but i'm the one that has to assemble it
and so yeah yeah you do
and selling directly to you no showrooms
no sales people no retail markups
there's not a lot of rigamarole and
right now articles offering our
listeners
50 off your first purchase of 100
or more go to article.com whitney
and the discount will be automatically
applied at checkout that's article.com
whitney to get 50 off your first
purchase of 100
or more um babble babble babble
wait we have to have a language what's
the language babble wait and hang on
guys what what language do i want to
learn this is like
i want to i want to um hang on i just
want to read over this really quick just
um
just one second i just want to read over
really quick just just really quick
babble guys babble now listen benton
do i i took french in high school do you
remember
i mention it i do babble
babble guys you can learn a language not
like
you not just learning one word or two
words you can learn
multiple languages they teach you
conversations it's like stuff that you
want to know i don't i don't need this i
don't need the ad
but it just tells you that they teach
you things guys babble has proven to get
you speaking languages in weeks
designed the course for real world
conversations in mind letting you learn
every day
practical conversations that you'll
actually use
just takes 10 or 15 minutes a day you're
going to start learning phrases this
share we have to get new chairs
new chairs guys this chair is making
we'll leave we'll cut this out but we'll
get new chairs
lessons are thoughtfully created with
over a hundred language experts a
hundred people
i don't know about you is there is there
a language you would want to learn ben
10 what do you want to learn do you want
to learn a language
um i want to brush up on my spanish do
it making noise
do you want to stop breathing in the
microphone i could stop hitting the
microphone you'd want to back up
it would it would improve the sound
quality of the show if i stopped
grabbing the microphone because i just i
do grab the microphone really
you're italian you talk with yourself oh
that's right i know yeah
yeah right right now so what oh what do
you want to learn uh i want to brush up
on my spanish
i love spanish as you're talking you're
looking at your glasses it doesn't seem
like that was a real question
they're truly perpetually dirty i can't
i can't get them clean i want to brush
up on my spandex and other glasses i
don't know where they are did you see my
hair is pink
um i want to you know that the border of
mexico i believe is now open america how
do you say good for you
in espanol no good for you in in the one
language i know french
bombos
i need to brush up on that because i am
on a dating app currently
i don't know who i'm playing at this
point in the ad but i'm on a dating app
currently a lot of the guys are in
germany and a lot of the guys are in
paris and i would like to brush
up on my german and parisian
and i'm in los angeles and refused to go
on a vacation so i don't know how that
will work
and i want to be able to flirt in other
languages
a lot can i tell you that was good that
was good um right now when you purchase
a three-month subscription babel will
give you
give you our listeners that's you three
additional months for free with promo
code good for you that's three
additional months for free if you go to
babel.com and use promo code good for
right now when you purchase a
three-month subscription babble will
give you our listeners an additional
three months free but promo code good
for you
that's three months free if you go to
babble.com and use promo code good for
you on our
friend why are you reading the ads i
don't have to read the ads when i do it
the green part we have to read the green
part
three month subscription that's
babble.com promo code good for you
good for you was that good should we do
that again
what's the female equivalent of a guy
coming on a girl's face what's the
female equivalent
i mean i guess him having a house
like what feels as good to a woman
as it is for a man to come on our faces
so he's like that and what would it be
for her
i mean you could sit on his face i mean
we can sit on their faces i do
i don't like it makes me feel
self-conscious because then your nose is
in my butthole
well oh if you're facing their knees
okay or your nose is if you're making
your way up to the top to sit on their
face
i have never sat on a guy's face oh i
have
but how do you know how low to go how do
you know but then aren't you engaging
your glutes aren't you having to
exercise by holding it isn't that like a
plank position
no where are you going but i'm just
saying
but then you guys this is wild
this shit just got crazy oh wow
their faces right here oh wow wait this
is crazy this is blowing my mind he
might have his hands in your butt or
something i don't know but hold on
the get why is it getting up so sad you
managed to make that like super boss
wait i didn't real okay what she did is
her knees went out so much that they
like
maybe i'm i'm not realizing everyone's
you're very flexible first of all
because i would have to just like
surfboard i would have used yoga
i would have to yeah i would have to
literally i know that you have something
to hold on to
and i'd have to use my muscles to squat
or like like like
oh you could also do jimmy what you know
what you just did when you said the um
when you said this like you used to be
kind of loud and stuff in bed yeah my
my thing of that in that same realm
would have been
on top like this instead of just like
kind of normally
yes like this i'm so sorry i don't know
i
love them i'm just saying i'm just
saying like that would have been my that
thing like he'll like this
like but if she was doing being on top
with
like bouncing sleep frog in her ankle
which by the way it's also like
i can be on top of you and you can fuck
from underneath that's just stay still
that's what i would do if i'm on top
that's just like you can
yeah do what i mean yeah i'm not in your
mind yeah like
i'm just like fully writing a script in
my head like trying to pay for
this house you get to fuck me um and
that
i don't i don't know i guess i
sitting on a guy's face i i've talked
about this before i don't
going down i've never been like that was
the most amazing i'd rather have sex
sure you know i think of it or you go
home and i masturbate
definitely foreplay for me like you're
staying like but when do you know it's
over when you know it's done when are
you like okay i'm going to dismount you
i mean this is like so i'm sharing like
a lot about my patterns
but uh and also until like an hour ago
going like are we friends
we're not really friends so this is how
i fucked that dick jesus
we went from zero to sixty
what if we just never talk again
what if i sit on your face
no also like this is coming to my mind
because it bothers me
it's like i am really tired of we're
doing it but i am so tired of people
being oh
female comics talking about sex it
really bothers me it's like the same
age-old bullshit of like
our women funny i'm like i think it's
just continuing because you keep saying
what is do you want to talk about like
airline food yeah what do you want to
talk about by the way it's like
also we're definitely helping you yeah
become better yeah
yeah this is a class yeah for you or
even
i don't hear that i don't really hear
that i like if i want to hear it i will
i'm saying i heard it so much that when
i first started other female comics say
that
like hater like comics when i first
started i remember thinking to myself i
won't talk about sex
like i don't want to play into that
stereotype yeah that was long ago not
that long but
yeah and so it took actually i'm not
kidding like a lot for me
to get over it and put a decent amount
of it in the special yeah i was like i'm
a grown woman
yeah i'll talk about what i want yeah
but i did kind of avoid it in some ways
oh please talk about politics i love
that
i know they don't want us to really die
yeah it's just like yeah there's
if you're fuck with me you fuck with me
and i can talk about anything and if you
know what i mean
yeah but for for me going down is for
sure like foreplay like that's to be a
must but how do you
really yeah like if we're making out i
like going down on someone
and i to me it's like a sign of like
compatibility and like
you want to please them and yeah so yeah
to me it's like it's definitely foreplay
going down on
maybe each other and then having sex and
then how do you get there you say no i'm
saying how do you know
how to when it's done or whatever yeah
like if you're like you could say things
like sorry i mean i'm just gonna tell
you things you're looking at
you could say things like i don't talk
during sex oh my god
i talk literally every other second of
the day that is the only time i shut my
whore mouth
hold on are you i'm not like
hold on i'll like make some noises but
i'm not going to get what you want by
not really saying
much oh you'll know yeah i'll roll over
i'll lean into it or lean
i'm not even like that feels so good in
there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i feel like i'll say like curse words
he's like like keep fucking or no like
damn yeah
yeah damn it yeah he's like did you stub
your tail
i'll just be like god damn it he's like
are you angry with me i don't
for fuck's sake yeah i don't i kind of
like need to focus
okay because if i start like trying or
forcing myself to
like i really have to yeah look if you
don't want to say anything it doesn't
come naturally then you absolutely
shouldn't
i'm always so realized it took me so
long to have an orgasm because i hold my
breath off
like i i have to say relax you really
have to
breathe and it's really hard i have to
really focus to be able to breathe
i've had for me it's more of like a
tenseness and a clenching
uh and it could just kegel not even
really with
that i mean definitely yes they do that
but i'm talking more like what do you
mean yes i wait okay i'm sorry
definitely yes i do that like you'll do
kegels during sex
yeah like the whole time throughout sex
yeah
so you're talking you're doing kegels
you're sitting on someone's face i'm
pitching a show on jesus christ
and this is a wild amount of
multitasking
really i can't do one of these things
okay people are like yeah do a kegel
during a second like yeah but i'm also
like
but to me it helps i forget it feels
good like obviously
again you are in control of your body
yeah that guy was right
i guess it's like you just i definitely
like you you have like a game plan you
go in with like a list
of things you want to accomplish yeah
but they all seem to typically happen in
a good exchange
yeah you know yeah like i seem to
and i don't yeah i don't know you like
take charge of your pleasure
yes yeah and they're but they're let's
let it also be known that
there are absolutely times where even if
i've slept with someone and i
and it maybe it's been a while and i go
back or something there have been times
where
like like i do like connection and i
kind of need that
like i do want to care about the person
yeah eye contact
i can't have sex with like strangers
yeah same like oh my god i need no
i need to know about your childhood
trauma before i am yeah i agree 100
yeah in fact you could argue that's why
i keep fishing in the same
pond because i like i i know what kind
of craze you are and i can find you
again
and i want when i want to
fix you through our sex
i want to heal an invisible wound
through my love like i have to know what
i'm fucking for
like i have to know what like void i'm
feeling like i need some kind of
emotional like entrenchment
you know what i mean i needed to be like
with us against the world like i need
some codependent motivation
okay you know i'm trying to think like
or just
alcohol yeah but i have also like i said
but i've gone back with somebody i did
feel that kind of connection and knowing
yes and have it not click
yes no if you don't have that emotional
connection it just feels so perfect but
then i've gotten it back with them tv
even casually yeah where i've been like
this because we talked about it
yeah so yes you downloaded it
so you to me i like being communicative
and
again though there are times where i
i like in my mind because like you're
saying i do take charge of it and i
would like to
yeah like i'm not dominating or anything
but i i know what makes me feel good so
i'm going to go for that but i also
don't
want care about them feeling good i'm
not someone who's like
get mine and leave yeah yeah i enjoy the
exchange yeah and the connection
yeah but there are times where i'm
bummed and disappointed and i wish i'd
been
more vocal or said this isn't working or
said like can you please this or there
have been times where
yeah because i did and i didn't reach
climax or something dude you like reach
climax
so you expect to have a climax every
time you have sex oh yeah
and i'm bummed if i don't this is a
while
this is a feminism got a muck okay
now we're just pushing it okay now i
feel like women i've just gotten a
little
a little too confident i came from
every 22 year old every time every time
i would like to yeah
okay yeah and if i don't i'm like a
little bummed good for you
and i'm happy and if i don't i want the
guy
i want to be able to have known that and
him know that and then him
take care of it i think there's because
there's something hot about
i think there is something this says so
much about my self-deprivation and
masochistic it takes there's something
hot about
not having an orgasm no i think there
is or something hot about a guy just
like using you and just like
like and just not and i don't want to
judge you
but i don't i want more for you i also
like a gun in my head
um and but i i also think there's
something
and i think this is i love you
this is sneaky but i think there's
something hot about not having an orgasm
and them having it and then them being
like
okay now i'm going to make you come but
with their hands okay and
yeah you can reach climax with i usually
have to just handle it okay
yeah but you can't just like kiss you or
something well yeah like let me go pee
first and i'll go
okay yeah yeah yeah or like you sit in
their lap or something
sure okay i mean i don't maybe i'd like
to know more about that
and then i profess yeah that's on the
bench
he puts on the bib and the bonnet and
you he takes off his diaper puts it on
you
and then i take him to school the next
morning but yeah i
i i oh my gosh and also it really is a
must for him to be open and willing to
go down on you even if you are
menstruating oh
there i i don't think people okay that's
you're wild
okay eating bread like a must okay that
is
gonna be so hot too you gotta
of me in my home with three lines of
blood on my face by the way
you can take our lives but you cannot
take our freedom
by the way also i changed my mind on the
narcissist you dated
the guy who's like no i'm not gonna eat
your pussy blood i actually think you
might be the narcissist
and you might be this like he's such a
narcissist he won't eat my pussy blood
let me sit on his face when i'm
hemorrhaging black cloths like jesus
okay i think he just had strong
boundaries i don't know i
i think it's because i came from someone
so down for anything like yeah
i i i mean that's how i i'm not having
sex i absolutely respect someone's
boundaries they said look
i'm so sorry i just don't know because i
haven't had my period in truly 15 years
so i i'm that would when guys are not
into having sex in their period that is
so whack and also is when it feels the
best
it feels so a lot of guys don't know
that it's lovely yeah yeah and you're
actually kind of like hornier and stuff
like it's the best
i just think it's great and say he had
like a strong aversion like you're
saying
to this but let's be real yeah going
back to our anatomy level by the way
what's better
it's the your other options fucking pee
right he was
like he was there there's not blood is a
step up from what was there before
yes but you know you have your vagina
here the bloods
what am i trying to say here so whatever
here's the vagina maybe uh-huh well i
don't know
um so maybe this is the
okay um your sisters
are just coiled up in my merch
i brought you a hat okay it's downstairs
yeah okay
whatever here's the hole or something in
here have your vagina here's the hole
yeah but here's your
clit or something so you this i
understand that's your you're looking
here
we learned last week with olivia munn or
two weeks ago that my vagina was like
really far back i watched that i was
laughing yeah so i'm trying to just
we learned my vagina's way back there
it's getting left behind quite often
this can't keep up
it's really quite sad but here's your
you know
hole and here's the clip got it so like
you're bleeding out of here and ideally
yeah you've kind of like if you want to
have sex in your period and you're cool
with and you talked about it
then you've kind of like again prepared
yourself maybe you took a shower
maybe you had a tampon in all day uh-huh
and then took a shower which
ceases your bleeding like i actually
don't love using tampons because i think
by the way
hot life hack well that's interesting
yeah
i had a gyno tell me that if i your
period goes faster if you put in a
tampon and sit in the bathtub
really and then pull it out and do it a
couple times oh that's interesting i
know
yep i mean he's not wrong i also think
you can do that
like if you're not afraid to touch
yourself and know your body and reach in
there and feel what's happening
then you can shower before and feel and
say am i bleeding a lot yeah they're a
lot going up there yeah take a shower
clean yourself and be like yeah like
you can make it not a massacre
you know like you can which boss used to
have this joke that probably is now
problematic
this joke that was so funny to me we go
um i don't mind having sex with girls on
her period i just pretend like i'm
killing her
like that was funny in the early odds we
got to make jokes like that
yeah it's like it's just i think you're
not licking the blood that's all i'm
saying you know
you're stimulating the clitoris yeah
it's down there interesting
you can't technically not taste blood at
all yes that's that's so that's my main
message here
interesting guys unless you have a long
beard
yeah then you're just dipping it in a
bowl of blood and coming out and
painting
his name on your belly roger was here it
is
roger i don't know i've never known her
roger have you
podector but that's it huh he's from
amazon roger pedector
oh no anyway i'm sorry i've never known
i don't think i know roger from rent
oh i know roger they call me i'm roger
that's all i know
there was a guy named roger there was a
teacher i had david roger now that i'm
thinking about it really
anyway sorry i feel like rogers are
sketchy
right am i right name a roger that's not
a criminal
exactly right they're all in jail that's
why we've never met them yep resume by
the name roger is just not
see ya later roger like what's the girl
equipment roger
like rita i like reading rita is
is rita's our i just went with always
colorful rita like do you know any rita
that's just like boring
what's the famous comic rudner thank you
mm-hmm and pass the test thank you
i don't hate women um i'm pro-i would be
playing
i really couldn't know rita right now
rita what's the other one renee i don't
know any like chill renee's
renee's are usually like dancing on the
bar like renee get down
i'm thinking of the ones i know and
renee's they're kind of
scared how your name like
like you wouldn't name your kid renee
obviously you wouldn't there's people
there's there's names that you imagine a
baby named renee
baby like a girl named renee yeah like
i know some renee's and i know what my
kid's name is going to be
really girl can you tell me dixie
really i like that that's just like i
just love that
i mean you know i don't want to ruin
anything for you but i like rocky too
dicks is in there dick's coming okay
yeah now you're making me i just want to
protect you and your future
child from dixie cummings is that going
to get bullied it's potentially
there's it's rife with potential
material
for her to get harassed at school if
there ever is a school
you just stole my future i go to school
so i'll be the one bullying yeah you're
going to have to hey dick
no i need a good joke for my child it
builds character
nobody stopped me and my daughter's name
did come
in her middle name's jizz her middle
name is
jizz string after bath because this is
gonna be on the internet forever
she's gonna get bullied one way or the
other do you want james i had some names
with like a partner of the past that i
read nice what were they can i say
yeah we always talked about calling our
daughter pearl
love it love it yeah it's so
weird because i i want to name a horse
pearl but i want to save it for
right and the other one love ruby i like
ruby i love really he always liked ruby
yeah
and um pearl is fucking great and then
the last one is is actually goldie we
know we love goldie and we have baldi's
yes i love a goldie i know a couple
goldie's now yeah you kind of i respect
the choice
i like uh nora a lot
from a doll's house i've always loved
that name i like tess and tessa i know
some tessa's and i just like
all the tests i know are just like bad
bitches that like test get it done
and it's not too masculine or feminine
it's just kind of like
tests like i'm like when he calls me
best yes
yeah when a test emails me i'm like got
it yeah
thank you for per your last email let's
go bitch like tesses are just like
in order yeah you know you see that i
like a state name i like a dakota
they're kind of strippery now but i like
a georgia i like uh
we had a georgia on the on the block
growing up that we really like georgia g
and franklin yeah a franklin neighbor
for the daughters were george and
franklin
frankie for a uh girl fantastic
yeah i have a dog named frankie so it
would probably just make me hate the
child because my dog might be dead by
that oh god
so took a good turn i don't want to be
right it really did what about boy names
boy names i've just i'm just banking on
not having one
i feel like i'm gonna go full pat
i feel like i'm gonna go lynn my dad's
middle name was lynn
i don't have any boy names i don't
either i was just
really fingers crossed for a girl sexist
yeah sorry i do well they're also trendy
i like a jackson and i like a jamison
okay i like a jack anything that's the i
think of all
growing up jack daniels jameson
sam adams sam adam's coming
yes in honor of my mother like i
i like i like a henry i like henry
i like uh harold like i like old-timey
names
roger except roger i'm trying to think
of my si like my
my nephew's names i mean i know them all
but like if
yeah i like them really read as one read
i like
i feel like reed was like a couple guys
that were like mean to me they were
named like reed
yeah you know my best friend's older
brother was reid and i always liked him
and he was good
yeah yeah um i like hunter i like all
those names i love a boy kelly
we have a boy i love a kelly mm-hmm i
did a guy named carrie
yeah i wouldn't do that from oh that
wouldn't be my channel it left a mark
trust me left a big mark i like a
basin i love a mason i love it george
i love i have a nephew named george and
it is so fucking he's a ten-year-old
george
it's so badass and he's so confident
like i truly think his name
gave him like a stature and a status i
like george
yeah it just was a good it's fun for
georgie is kind of fun
right and the youth i love a status
scene i love a sherwood
i am not on board with that oh sure why
not sherwood
forest yeah i grew up with a sherwood
florist so i can't
that's just triggered like i like a like
a big name like that
yeah oh we did have a boy named
knox k-n-o-x knox i like knoxville oh
johnny knoxville knox forever knox is so
good
that would be my number one boy name
wait knox i think he wanted to name
um reese witherspoon named one of her
kids tennessee
i like that i love um nash nashville
like nash nash like i like for some
reason girls are states and
america boys are cities americas
americas
trying to think of what you wanted to
name it really intense i know who won
the name of that
the boy who i might have had a parole
with oh
yeah well you lost me on that yeah
yeah oh is it will ferrell's kid's name
that reminds me
magnus love i love a bruno i love a
magnus
i love like uh um what about
tito big name tito's tito's the bot i
just think yeah that's a vodka that's
the only problem i think of the vodka
i think it's charlie i'll always love it
i love charlie i like a charles for a
boy and charlie for a girl
charles for charlie's a little like
charlie girl it's a little like
strippery
charlie that's from um all dogs go to
heaven when the little wiener dogs like
char
like i just feel like charlie's male
charlie's have to have like polio
you know what i mean like charlie like
the chocolate factory i think
i'm thinking of like a sick kid
it's like oliver yeah speaking of oliver
i love oliver but i feel like
everyone's doing that it's a lot of
oliver so olivia's and oliver's
apparently like the schoolyards remember
those
are all oliver i like olivia some people
in my life but i don't like i don't i
wouldn't name my kid olivia olivia
yeah but yeah i love this this is my
dream conversation just
talk about names and the conversation
that goes absolutely nowhere
literally it's just the most useless
conversation
and everyone that lists this podcast
we've mentioned all of their names
and we've alienated at least half of the
audience shout outs like that's my name
that's my name that's my kid's name
sorry anyone's feelings we heard about
your name just hurts so many people's
feelings for no reason
names are very sensitive names and
horoscopes are very sensitive it's true
isn't it weird how names
there's people i grew up with that i
wouldn't name my kid because that name
reminds me of them
so but also there is people who have the
same name are kind of similar
you think kind of what's another fact
that i'm like
beth's my best i mean i don't know her
though she's
fucking delightful like you you're both
delightful
um and honest and friends with me okay
and i don't i don't have any bad
associations with beth okay bethany
i had a bethany who was one of my best
friends in virginia i love all
that i didn't know any shitty baths but
that's good i don't know any shitty
baths hell yes
you hear that best out there i know some
like shitty
i know some like amazing veronicas and
like some shitty veronicas these aren't
pretty sweaty this one yeah i'm swampy
i'm not hot in here though but this
armpit's wet
okay sorry okay i'm fine yeah no i know
i'm not i wasn't planning on do you see
ending the no i we can't see it okay
good
no oh you're worried that no yeah just
like
that's what yeah i used to actually use
these oh i remember you talking about it
i used to have like masks
soda you do i know who you are i knew a
lot about you i just didn't think you
wanted to be my friend
i didn't think you want to be my friend
i thought you were too cool for me the
oh
meets the club i know i thought it was
like too mainstream for you
um but yeah my lips are chat but they're
fine we've been here for three and a
half hours really have to no we've been
no
so we have to end this but i do
i've never licked my lips this morning
what's your middle name duval
it's my mom's maiden name i just like
put my hair over here yeah what's
happening
are you did you do the thing where you
try to scrape the smeg off your lips
yeah what was that that's what is that
i do this because in the corner i just
i'm worried like that it's
you know on my way here i noticed that i
had toothpaste right here i'm always
afraid that i'm going to have that like
crust on my lips
same and so i have to like do this yeah
i hope i don't it's really hard to get
off
i i i fix it in post okay we clean this
up and pose
paint my face yeah no i i feel like that
and then i do
uh wipe my under eyes because i always
think that my eyeliner is running
or the mascara yeah because i can
actually
cry without anyone knowing really yes
i can cry while like having a
conversation with you where do the tears
you'll never know they just like
reabsorb into my skin did i make you cry
no i haven't gone today actually i
didn't cry during this at all
yeah i puked a couple times and
swallowed it back down
do you have any questions for me um
wow i mean i wasn't prepared for this
part
that's just such a funny way to like i
had such a funny podcast to have people
on it be like so what do you want to ask
me
what would you like to know yeah you
make the guess the host everybody asks
you anything i wanted to ask oh i always
ask red flags any red flags just to
throw out
and then what do you mean like if i see
him in somebody like we just like
like to pass on our good for your
podcast like just red flags that you've
seen
that we can pass on to people like too
many selfies on their grid
hates their mom talk shit about their
exes
all of those yeah like do you have any
ones that you can pass on to the
listeners
so that they can avoid a tricky
relationship
it's a hard one yeah it is it doesn't
eat your bearded blood yeah that's a big
one
it's a huge red flag blood red
yeah like oh i was gonna i can't i had
it yeah i lost it i have like
where's too many necklaces oh oh
a guy that wears like a bracelet and a
necklace it's a little munch oh it's
more like
don't wear two necklaces if you haven't
bought me any
[Music]
has more jewelry for himself than he's
bought as a gift for me that's true
that's a good one you know what i mean
gosh i'm really trying to little ones
it's like little ones oh how about red
flag
turns their phone over at dinner oh yeah
why can't you turn your phone face up
yeah what are you worried about yeah a
17-digit password what are we doing yeah
like like cups the screen of their phone
while they're talking
it just moves it away from you it's like
what are you doing yeah don't worry it
was plugged into the car and get a text
and they unplug it
i mean that's just like that's not even
a red flag that's just something that
happens yeah that's just get out of the
car
yeah you know better not talk to them
yeah it's like and if
i'm asking you and we'll and then
gaslighting 101 is like what do you mean
i'm just unplugging my phone what are
you why are you freaking out it's like
you know that was weird
uh-huh like and then you're like was it
weird it wasn't you did it it's how you
did it you know
you know you're texting with some girl
and trying to hide it
you know you programmed her in as
another name be honest
yeah yeah who's derek you know you
programmed some girl named mia in as
derek
who's derek when do i get to meet derek
let's go see meet him right now
and take me to dairy may take me to
derek's house okay okay
like anything in the house like like i
had one
i opened a drawer at once and found
concealer and i was like oh shit whose
is this
what girl's been staying here and he was
like that's mine no
someone that like i feel like if you
have concealer left over from an x that
you're using to cover zits and under eye
stuff if you're a guy
i'm fine with it congratulations on
having the same skin tone
yeah like someone has a diaper that's a
true narcissist yeah someone who only
dates people with the same
skin tone exactly yeah like i just was
like
and i i was like oh don't be judgmental
it was just he ended up being very vain
and
self-obsessed yeah that kind of just
told me that
gosh i'm really wishing that i had more
red flags but part of me doesn't want to
be brutal right now you know what i feel
like watch your spot i feel like you
have stuff in your special
i feel like everything you talk about
your special is gonna end up being a red
flag take away yeah there you have it
hbo max it's probably it's going to come
out a couple days after this podcast
coming out so just subscribe to hbo max
watch it lol girl daddy girl
daddy what it was like girl
girl daddy jesus christ say that that
wild juxtaposition of words in a way
that's like a little less upsetting
um and on instagram twitter
beth stelling dot whatever you want
edu.edu
i end these very awkwardly don't ride
elephants
do all the things you're supposed to do
don't embarrass yourself or me
okay no i'm just like okay
like subscribe you know what to do and
if you haven't done it by now you don't
want to and that's fine
and i'll be okay